what do you think you would be doing for
a career if your dad wasn't Jordan
Peterson before Dad got famous I started
writing a Blog called don't eat that
which is now it's been transported over
to liondiet.com I started getting
invited onto podcasts this is before I
went on Rogan to talk about diet my
experience with diet so I do think that
even if Dad wasn't my dad I would have
gone down the diet route and tried to
educate people on what had helped me
that's where I would have started I
would have written my book because I'd
already been writing my book and I
really enjoyed podcasting so I may have
just started a podcast anyway maybe I
would have finished my biomedical
science degree but I think I would have
just gone into the diet root instead
because that works for chronic disease I
think I would be in a similar place but
I wouldn't be launching Peterson Academy
and I wouldn't have as much of an
audience for sure it would have just
started in the diet realm and kind of
spread out from there